all right Joe uh Rogan Joe Rogan podcast
host Joe Rogan is positive for covid and
he is taking like seven different drugs
and treatments including Ivermectin a
horse dewormer and anti-parasitic in
some doses for humans okay all right
well we'll talk about that this is
notable for a couple of different
reasons first actually maybe we'll look
at the video clip first but to set the
stage
this is the same Joe Rogan yeah on Whose
show I've appeared twice and I don't he
he may never have me back on because
I've been critical of the things he said
about covet and vaccines this is the
same Joe Rogan who said if you're
healthy and you're eat right like he
does you don't need to be vaccinated
um let's look at the video clip of Joe
Rogan explaining what happened listen to
the list of medications and treatments
that he's on
um and then there's there's much to
discuss here
Hello friends so I got back from the
road Saturday night feeling very weary I
had a headache and I just felt just run
down and just to be cautious I separated
from my family slept in a different part
of the house and throughout the night I
got fevers and sweats and I knew what
was going on so I got up in the morning
got tested and turns out I got covered
so we immediately threw the kitchen sink
out of all kinds of meds monoclonal
antibodies
Ivermectin zpac
prednisone everything and I also got an
nadrip and a vitamin drip and I did that
three days in a row
and so here we are on Wednesday
and I feel great I really only had one
bad day Sunday sucked but Monday was
better Tuesday felt better than Monday
and today I feel good I actually feel
pretty [ __ ] good uh that's the good
news the bad news is we have to move
Friday the Friday show in Nashville okay
so um there's a bunch of stuff that is
important to talk about here now again
people have been every time I talk about
Joe Rogan and the vaccine stuff or
whatever people write to me to say David
I thought you were friends with Joe I've
been on Joe's show twice we've
corresponded via Twitter a few times I
would be I would say any of this to Joe
um and this is not like some hot take
take down I'm going to tell you what I
think kind of doesn't make sense about
all of this there's the macro and
there's the micro okay the big picture
story from from Rogan has been this is
not serious enough where young healthy
people should really go and get
vaccinated it doesn't make sense
um in in a what's interesting is way
back when I I was last on with Joe he
said he did think wearing masks Outdoors
made sense even though I was kind of
saying at the time I'm not really sure
about that more recently with Bill Burr
he said masks outside are you wearing a
mask outside sort of like that doesn't
make sense
um he talked about how this is not
something that is serious enough that if
you are not an at-risk individual if
you're if you're healthy and eating
right or whatever you don't really need
to be vaccinated now that immediately
raises the question
as a healthy person who eats right and
stays fit
why then did Joe Rogan need seven
medications and treatments or five five
or six medications and treatments
including things that aren't actually
approved by the FDA either at all other
outside of emergency use or aren't
approved by the FDA for covid
um that is you know that Joe Rogan's
argument was no vaccine for a lot of
people because the benefits don't
outweigh the risks covet isn't that
serious healthy people work out eat
right but then you're throwing the
kitchen sink at it that doesn't really
make sense you don't need the vaccine if
Rogan really didn't get it I'm taking
him at his word that he didn't get it
you know we hear about people who were
secretly vaccinated I have no reason to
believe that Joe Rogan would do that
there are some right-wing hosts who we
later found out or right-wing
politicians I believe Rogan hasn't
gotten the vaccine uh but then you're
throwing the kitchen sink at it and it's
important also to understand
we're going to go through the
medications a lot of people wouldn't
have access or wouldn't be able to
afford all of this stuff either so there
were there were some people who were
hearing this and they're saying look
Rogan was right he had one bad day he's
not vaccinated and now he's fine of
course that's to some degree chance but
also we'll talk about the NAD drips and
vitamin drips and all these things
whether or not those things do anything
if you believe that they do
a lot of that stuff's not covered by
insurance and the average person can't
handle that the vaccine is free it's
important to remember that now let's go
to the micro okay so Rogan says he took
monoclonal antibodies that is only
approved via emergency use authorization
it's available relatively widely
but remember that the Pfizer vaccine is
fully approved by the FDA uh and and
same as moderna which is only approved
by emergency use for now although in a
couple of weeks it will likely be fully
approved the use of monoclonal
antibodies is experimental in the same
sense that they've been saying the
vaccine is so number one on the list is
something that's only approved by eua so
I'm not sure why someone would hesitate
on the vaccine over lack of approval but
then go and take the monoclonal
antibodies that's a hypocrisy I'm not
saying it's Rogan's hypocrisy but for
people who are saying the antibodies are
available that's as experimental as all
the vaccine were up until 10 days ago
and now Pfizer is actually approved to a
more strict level now then there's
Ivermectin Ivermectin is a frequently
used cattle medication it is sometimes
used in humans as well there's no
denying that in different doses as of a
few days ago the big paper that a lot of
people were pointing to to say
Ivermectin works for covid it's based on
Egyptian data that was retracted why
they didn't have a proper placebo group
that the Egyptian paper a lot of people
point to was Ivermectin versus
hydroxychloroquine not Ivermectin versus
placebo the way you're supposed to do it
in a double-blind randomized controlled
trial then a group called the Cochrane
collaboration looked at all of the
meta-analyzes of the clinical trials on
Ivermectin they found that a bunch of
the individual studies had problems just
like the Egyptian one and once you look
at just the studies that are done
correctly they say there is very low to
low certainty evidence that Ivermectin
is at all effective on covid-19
okay World Health Organization
infectious disease Society of America
even the manufacturer of ivermectin
Merck say there is no meaningful
evidence for clinical uh efficacy in
covid-19 with Ivermectin last week the
FDA started warning people don't go and
get ivermectin for covid-19 and now the
American Medical Association is asking
doctors do not give anybody ivermectin
for covet 19. so that's the second thing
that Rogan is taking importantly not
approved even under emergency use
authorization for covid the Pfizer
vaccine is fully approved lastly real
quick before we move on how did how do
people start trying Ivermectin and stuff
like hydroxychloroquine the the basics
are at the beginning of all this
when we didn't have a treatment we
didn't have vaccines
um doctors in different parts of the
world started trying cheap stuff that's
just around hydroxychloroquine has been
around a really long time and it's very
cheap Ivermectin is very very cheap so
they start trying it and if you have
small cohorts of 20 30 patients
and most people recover from covet
anyway you're likely to get what is some
apparent efficacy signal if you just
have a bunch of random doctors saying
here I'm going to give 30 of my patients
Ivermectin or I'm going to give 30 of my
patients hydroxychloroquine by chance
you might get what appears to be an
efficacy signal uh and you're just
throwing this stuff at it because it's
cheap and available but that's not how
we actually do science okay so that's
Ivermectin zpac this is the antibiotic
azithromycin now you would say why would
you take an antibiotic for something
that's a virus and you would be right
there are some ideas that certain
antibiotics could have an antiviral
effect against some viruses it's been
studied with covid and azithromycin it
doesn't appear to be the case uh study
looked at a single dose of Azithromycin
and it didn't change the proportion of
covet patients who were symptom-free
versus symptomatic after 14 days now you
might say well David why are they only
getting one dose
typically azithromycin is given you know
as a as a course of treatment another
study
um looked at intravenous azithromycin 10
doses over 10 days it also didn't
statistically improve uh outcomes okay
so that's the third thing Rogan is
taking fourth prednisone prednisone is
one of many steroids and remember that
there was the discussion of
dexamethasone for covid earlier in the
pandemic this is a very basic idea this
is the idea that steroids can mitigate
the inflammatory response and that
inflammatory response can lead to lung
injury in covid so you give the steroid
it reduces the inflammatory response in
the lungs maybe it helps people recover
maybe it helps people just feel better
in the short run that's generally
connected to reality if you have
inflammation you look at using a steroid
but unless you're actually having lung
compromise it's really not clear that it
makes sense to take steroids it can have
nasty side effects it can actually make
you worse with some respiratory viruses
in previous outbreaks of Novel
coronavirus infections like MERS the
Middle East Respiratory Syndrome or SARS
corticosteroid therapy sometimes
actually extended how long people had
the virus in their system so it's really
unclear
um and uh there so so that's kind of
like a question mark we don't know how
involved Rogan's lungs were it may have
made sense to try throwing a steroid at
it or maybe not the other stuff isn't
really even medication the NAD drip
that's a nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide they it's very En Vogue
right now to do these drips it's there's
no indication it helps with covid same
thing with IV vitamins it's very popular
for wealthy folks to start getting these
IV drips I know people who do it there's
no reason to think that it helps with
covet now then there's the the the final
thing here
if this stuff works okay let's just
imagine all this stuff works covid must
be pretty freaking serious to throw all
of this stuff at it and what I mean by
that is if covet weren't serious if
kovid were just the flu
then you wouldn't if you were Joe Rogan
be taking Monica monoclonal antibodies
Ivermectin antibiotics steroids vitamins
and an NAD IV
three days in a row that's pretty
serious right do you really want to take
all that stuff each with its own side
effect risk if covid isn't that serious
for someone who eats right or works out
or is generally healthy that's
completely incongruous and with the flu
you don't go and take seven medications
and treatments so uh that's the real
important takeaway here I would love to
talk to Rogan about this he may have
seen my last clips about him and decided
I'm not having David Pacman on anymore
he may not even be aware of the clips I
have no idea but I welcome the
opportunity to talk to him about it if
you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much I
love my Helix mattress well I was really
excited to hear that Helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium customizable sofas and
chairs with the same level of quality
and comfort that I expect from these
guys and all form is one of our sponsors
today they're giving you twenty percent
off off at allforum.com Pacman they
actually sent me a couch which I put in
my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture in the house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
I love but it's also very comfortable
fabric is soft clearly very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room their prices are very
reasonable and when you get a new sofa
or chair you get 100 days to decide if
you want to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty stop buying poorly made
Furniture go to customize your own all
form sofa or chair right now and get 20
off your entire order when you get there
by going to allforum.com Pacman I've
also put the link right underneath this
video